let's start back at the beginning shall
we
Los Angeles 2001 humble roots local kids
Street Racers who became hijacked
graduated to high-speed smuggle
mobile jailbreaks Train Robbers
if it could be done in the car they did
it
if it violates the laws of God and
gravity
they did it twice
but the days were one man behind the
wheel if a car can make a difference are
over
it's time to prepare for what's coming
you might want to buckle up
as I look out at this wonderful family I
am filled with so much pride
great Dome Toretto
if you never would have gotten behind
that wheel
I'd never be the man I am today
and now I am the man who's going to
break your family
Peace by peace
what's up Uncle Jacob your dad sent me
can't wait to get out of this one
let's go
dummy I knew you would come for me I'm
Dante I'm Shantae so how about we all
just start shooting each other that's
what I tender for time to end this
[Applause]
let's dig some Graves
you are not to be trusted are you in on
my Christmas list either
calvary's here
it's showtime cute tiny Dash
no no we never agreed on that
pictures
we need weapons
and cars
holy Shannon cars that was awesome do
you like surprises I adore them
how much time do we have about four
minutes it'll have to do
foreign
I'd stay down if I was you you'll need
to hit me harder for that
the game's over down
you lose
this is your last ride
Maybe This Is the End
know what
I smell magic
they say when you're facing death your
life flashes before your eyes
are they right if this is the finish
line I'm not afraid
[Music]
thank you